this is CNN breaking news police in
Ferguson hold apologetic press
conference ahead of grand jury decision
I can assure you we have learned our
lesson to those of you in the Suburban
neighborhoods that we mistakenly tear
gassed
we are so so sorry this time
we will ensure that the only people to
be gassed will be the angry
Urban individuals we know that bringing
the National Guard into our small
Midwestern town in the middle of a
civilian protest was viewed as scary so
this time we're bringing in the soldiers
now
this way we will be using military
tactics on civilian protesters from the
very beginning officers will wear their
regular police uniforms
the militarized body armor and
submachine guns will go underneath we
acknowledge that we previously forced
journalists out of a McDonald's and
detained them
from now on we will make sure that
journalists are detained in the
McDonald's where they may benefit from
free Wi-Fi once we return their laptops
and cell phones
they may also have healthy fruit
parfaits you may have seen officers
making threats such as I will [__]
kill you with their guns pointed at
people if necessary we will simply close
our eyes and make punching motions in
the air
thus any civilian or journalist who
would like to avoid being hurt
can simply do what we say and get out of
our way use of rubber bullets will be
minimized as well they can be dangerous
when used like last time to shoot
journalists from Al
Jazeera
in our defense that sounds very similar
to Al-Qaeda to sum up
by bringing the military in and taking
other small measures now
we hope to avoid anything like what
happened last August
thank you for your time and we will look
forward to your peacefulness
now shut those [__] cameras off
before I [__] shoot you
I'm sorry old happened